so let's get a little bit more comfort
in our understanding of what a
differential equation even is and so
here we have a differential equation and
we haven't started exploring how we find
the solutions for differential equations
yet but let's just say you saw this and
someone just walked up to you on the
street and says hey
i will give you a clue
that there's a solution to this
differential equation that is
essentially a linear function where y is
equal to mx plus b and you just need to
figure out the m's and the b's or maybe
the m and the b that makes this makes
this linear function satisfy this
differential equation
and what i now encourage you to do is
pause the video and see if you can do it
so i'm assuming you have paused it and
had a go at it so let's think this
through together
so if we know that this kind of a
solution can be described in this way we
have to figure out some m's and b's here
this is telling us that if we were to
take the derivative of this with respect
to x if we take the derivative of mx
plus b with respect to x that that
should be equal to negative 2 times x
plus 3 times y well we know y is this
thing
minus 5. and that should be true for all
x's in order for this to be a solution
to this differential equation remember
solution of differential equation is not
a value or a set of values it is a
function or a set of functions so in
order for this to be to satisfy this
differential equation it needs to be
true for all of these x's here so let's
work through it let's figure out first
what our d y d x is
so d y d x we'll just take the
derivative here with respect to x d y d
x is derivative of m x with respect to x
is just going to be m
and of course derivative of b with
respect to x is just a constant so it's
just going to be zero so d y d x is m
so we could write m
is equal to negative two x
is equal to
negative 2x
plus 3 times
instead of putting y there i could write
mx plus b remember y is equal to mx plus
b
and this is a repeated reminder this has
to be true for all x's
m
x
plus b
and then of course we have the minus
five
and so if you weren't able to solve it
the first time i encourage you to start
from here and now figure out what m what
m and b needs to be in order for this
equation right over here in order for
this to be true for all x's in order for
this to be true for all x's
so i'm assuming you have paused again
and had to go at it so let's just keep
algebraically manipulating this and i'll
i'll just switch to one color here so we
have m
m is equal to
negative two x
plus if we distribute this three we're
gonna have three m x plus three b
and then of course we're going to have
minus 5. and now we can group the x
terms so if we were to group
if we were to group let me find a new
color here maybe this blue so if we were
to take these two and add them together
that's going to be
negative 2 plus 3m times x or we could
write this as 3m
minus 2
times x and then you have your constant
terms
so you have these terms right over here
so plus
3b
minus 5 and of course that's all going
to be equal to m
that's going to be equal to m
now remember this needs to be true this
needs to be true for all x's
so notice over here i have some i have
some coefficient times x on the right
hand side but on the left-hand side i
have no x's
so somehow this thing must disappear
this this is a constant so it's
completely reasonable it's completely
reasonable that this constant could be
equal to m
but the only way that i get these x's to
disappear so all i'm left with is an m
is if this thing is equal to zero let me
say that again because i think it might
maybe be a little bit counter-intuitive
what i'm about to do we're saying that m
some constant value is equal to some
coefficient times x plus some other
constant value
well in order for a constant value to be
equal to a coefficient times x plus some
other constant value the coefficient on
x must be equal to zero another way to
think about it is
this should be
you could rewrite the left hand side
here as zero x
plus m and so you see you kind of match
the coefficients
so 0 must be equal to 3m minus 2 and m
is equal to 3b
m is equal to 3b minus 5.
m is equal to 3b minus 5.
so let's let's use that knowledge that
information to solve for m and b
so we could use this first one so 3m
minus 2 must be equal to 0. so let's
write that 3 m minus 2 is equal to 0 or
3 m is equal to two or m is equal to two
thirds so we figured out what m is
and then we could use that information
because we know that
we know that m
is equal to
is equal to three b
minus five
m is two thirds so we get two thirds is
equal to three b minus five we could add
five to both sides which is the same
thing as adding
15 thirds to both sides
is that did i do that right yeah it's
adding 5 to both sides the same thing as
adding 15 thirds to both sides let's do
that 15
over 3
plus 15 over 3 these cancel out that's
just 5 right over there on the left hand
side
we have 17
over 3 is equal to 3
b
or if you divide both sides by 3 you get
b
is equal to 17
b is equal to 17
over
9. and we're done we just found the
a particular solution for this
differential equation the solution is
y
is equal to
two thirds x
plus
17 over nine and i encourage you after
watching this video to verify that this
particular solution in indeed does
satisfy this differential equation for
all x's for
all x's